my favorite comment yesterday my
favorite comment in a while actually is
from Donna varapodio who says the longer
I live on this planet the more I
understand why roosters start their day
screaming
I I feel you and actually that's a great
segue into into a clip that I have to
bring up I just saw it this morning from
our friend Tennessee local Kid Rock
who in his typically articulate and
pithy fashion has responded to Bud
light's recent sponsorship
of the transvestite Dylan Mulvaney
here is
kids response
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
let me uh say something to all you and B
as clear and concise as possible
[Laughter]
Bud Light and Anheuser-Busch
have a terrific day
foreign
in so few words he summed up with so
many of us were thinking by the way we
always talk about what's an assault
weapon what's a fully automatic weapon I
think that one is an assault weapon I
think pretty sure that one is whatever
assault weapon means it probably means
that fully automatic weapon the Kid Rock
has which are very hard to get in which
we highly regulate in America and for
those of you who are only listening to
that and didn't see it the object of his
fire was
two 12 packs of Bud Light
and it's an important statement too
because Kid Rock is not only a rock star
but he he owns the biggest Honky Tonk in
Nashville
the biggest most impressive Honky Tonk
in Nashville which is Music City is Kid
Rock's big ass honky Tonkin rock and
roll Steakhouse great name for an
establishment so I assume they're going
to get rid of Bud Light at The Honky
Tonk and I think we should all get rid
of Bud Light in our homes I almost never
drink Bud Light though if I'm at the
kind of place where I'm gonna drink a
regular light beer like that
I previously had ordered Bud Light
because it's just tastes kind of like
nothing now I'm going to have to order
something else it's so offensive
the Bud Light would partner with this
guy Dylan Mulvaney
it's so offensive that they would
partner with a guy who makes an absolute
mockery of women and of the difference
between men and women it's absolutely
offensive that that Bud Light would
announce this days after a transgender
identifying person shot up a Christian
School a in a targeted shooting
according to the chief of police
apparently motivated by transgender
ideology we're not allowed to say that
definitively because we haven't gotten
any more information we haven't seen a
Manifesto but the facts as they appear
right now are pretty clear and what is
what does Bud Light do the same thing
the White House does the same thing that
the Department of Health and Human
Services do same thing the media do they
say you know the real victims here are
the transgender identifying people and
if you don't support transgenderism
you're a terrible awful person
transgenderism is the state religion and
you will comply with it
and Kid Rock says Nope
and we can all say nope as well on this
show I focus a lot on macro political
issues political trends that do not just
cover weeks or months but cover decades
or centuries that's just what I am most
interested in and I think it explains
the most about our current political
situation when you look at these
cultural religious philosophical and
practical political trends
however
I don't want to neglect the importance
of individual political Administrations
Saudi Arabia is just announced that it's
going to cut oil production by a million
barrels of oil a day
Saudi Arabia will lead the members of
OPEC including Russia
to cut that million barrels of output a
day starting next month
this will cause higher U.S inflation
Saudi Arabia then said
it would cut production by another half
million barrels a day
starting in May why is Saudi Arabia
doing this
because it doesn't like Joe Biden
Saudi Arabia one of our best allies in
the Middle East we had a great
relationship with Saudi Arabia for many
decades and Trump had a great
relationship with Saudi Arabia and then
Joe Biden
because he wanted to suck up to Iran
decided to try to make a pariah of Saudi
Arabia Joe Biden because he was bungling
into the the war in Ukraine in a war
which he largely enabled even according
to Ukrainian president zielinski tried
to make a pariah of Saudi Arabia and
Saudi Arabia didn't like that Joe Biden
who then tried to make up for his
failures by releasing a huge amount of
our strategic petroleum Reserve to try
to get himself through the midterm
elections Saudi Arabia didn't like that
too much and so now Saudi Arabia is
striking back
in just two years this Administration
has wrought
such destruction on the United States
completely destroyed our economy
further exacerbated greatly exacerbated
the problems of our illegal immigration
system
uh
Bears much of the responsibility for
starting the first major war in Europe
since World War II potentially the
beginning of World War III
destroyed our energy sector eggs now
cost nine dollars a dozen
they just they've just ruined everything
they just the record is a record of pure
failure the likes of which we have not
seen since Jimmy Carter
this just is what happened under Jimmy
Carter we're supposed to say that
history doesn't repeat itself but it
does Rhyme this is just repetition this
is repeating itself
this is barely a rhyme anymore this just
seems to be a full on
copy
this man
is the worst president I've ever seen
and I mean that not even in his degree
of radicalism or evil he doesn't he is
the most radical president but only
because that's the way that the wind and
his party is blowing Joe Biden doesn't
believe a thing and he never has
Obama was a little more focused and a
little more ideological than Biden
but Barack Obama was also more competent
than Biden and just on the on the basic
matters of competence Joe Biden is
terrible you would think that would be
the one thing that Joe Biden would be
pretty good at because he's been around
the federal government for over 50 years
now Joe Biden was first elected to the
U.S Senate in the early 70s
and he remained there until he became
the vice president then he was vice
president until 2016 and then four years
later he became the president so he's
all in an almost uninterrupted track
he's been in the government forever
you'd think he could just do the basic
stuff and he can't the country's falling
around around us
because not only do we have a wicked and
absurd ideology that is insisting that
we all live in lies constantly that's
not going to lead to National
flourishing but he also just can't do
the basic stuff that government requires
we got a guy on
friend of mine who wants to have the top
job in the country
that would be my friend Vivek ramaswamy
so get your questions for Vivek in
we will be Fielding your questions
for the vague coming up here on the
member block the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
go to dailywire.com
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
laughs
foreign